hi i have an announcement to make this
week at linc we're launching a
proficiency test
which you can do and have fun with
uh try to measure your level of
proficiency in the language that you're
studying at the present moment we have
this for english french spanish german
portuguese and russian only we
will perhaps expand it to other
languages so if you are learning any of
those languages or if you are a speaker
of those languages
learning english you'll be able to use
the test and you can do it as many times
as you want it's quite fun i've done it
it's kind of addictive
we can talk about it on the format link
you can compare yourself to your friends
it's also maybe useful in terms of um
trying to figure out what level you're
at so that when you go about choosing
content in our library or you wish to
know what level you are
within link this might be helpful
but it's mostly meant to be fun
oh and i should add that uh it works on
your uh uh you know iphone or android
phone so it's it's portable so if you're
out somewhere waiting uh you can simply
do this little test and because you can
do them as often as you want and it'll
take you up through different levels uh
it should keep you busy for quite a
while so please enjoy it and i look
forward to hearing people's reactions to
it and i'm gonna leave a link here in
the description so that you can go and
get started testing yourself bye for now